- Quatre mois se sont écoulés
depuis que la Russie a lancé les
premières bombes sur l'Ukraine.
Il y a eu les condamnations,
puis une avalanche de sanctions.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais la vie en apparence n'a pas
vraiment changé à Moscou.
Même le McDonald a rouvert.
Les Russes ont racheté tous les
restaurants et les exploitent
désormais sous le nom de
"Délicieux, point c'est tout".
Un pied de nez à l'Occident,
qui, malgré tout, n'a pas réussi
à étouffer l'économie russe.
Et tant bien que mal, la vie ici
continue. La guerre, qu'on soit
pour ou contre, se discute loin
des caméras, censure oblige.
Tout ira bien, nous dit celui
qui monte la garde du matin
au soir, devant l'immeuble
où  le bureau de Radio-Canada
a pignon sur rue depuis 1978,
à Moscou. C'est ici, sur la rue
Gruzinski, que la presse
étrangère s'était installée
à l'époque; et Radio-Canada
n'est jamais parti.
- Ah, look at you!
You look amazing!
- Fidèle au poste,
Irina Melnikova, notre doyennene
et administratrice, aura été là
jusqu'à la fin.
C'est le Kremlin qui a ordonné
la fermeture de notre bureau
à titre de représtre
le gouvernement canadien,
et nous n'y pouvons strictement
rien. Il faut se résigner,
et nous avons seulement quelques
jours pour vider le bureau
de ses souvenirs, et surtout,
quitter nos collègues.
Elena Dabbakh était notre
e est interprète.
Le dictionnaire des expressions
soviétiques.
ui! Toujours!
On peut tuer avec ça.
(rires)
- Une bonne vivante et une
édie. Toujours au fait
du moindre détail sur l'histoire
de son pays.
C'est quoi?
- C'est le plan quinquennal.
- Au lieu de tout jeter,
on a pas trouvé preneur chez
ces jeun. Ils ont. Ils ont. Ilst
aussi pris nos meubles pour leur
nouvelle pratique qui se
consacre à la défense des droits
de la pe
de la communauté LGBT.
Olga est une juriste. Elle ne
connaissait pas Radio-Canada,
prend très bien
ce qui est en jeu.
Le pays se referme, mais ces
Le pays se referme, mais ce
jeunes bravent la tempête, alors
que tant d'autres ont quitté
la Russie. Ça fait du bien de r;
quoique modeste,
il a bien servi.
Donc, c'est comme une seconde
s au moins, on sait
qu'on jette pas ça à la
poubelle, puis que ça... ça va
servir à des jeunes qui nousnt t
le besoin de rester en Russie,
qu'il y a beaucoup, beaucoup
d'ONG qu
Alexei dit que 60 % de son
entourage, des activistes et
des militants, ont plié bagages.
Faire le ménage, c'est aussi
revivre l'histoire du pays
en accéléré. Certains chapitres
traînent encore dans un coin
du bureau, sur ces vieilles
cassettes. "Sur l' "Sur l' "Sur,
bordel économique."
Ça, c'est 1993. "Résultats
des élections"...
Poutine n'était pas encore dans
le paysage.
C'était une autre époque
complètement, c'était les années
de la chute de l'Union
soviétiq
- Cette transition est si
douloureuse qu'un Russe
sur quatre...
- C'est Céline Galipeau quiétai0
pour rapporter les premiers
balbutiements d'une Russie
démocratique.
- Merci de nous recevoir, le pr.
- Le journaliste Michel Cormier
aura quant à lui assisté au
début de l'ère de Vladimir
Poutine.
- Vladimir Poutine,
l'un des obstacles majeurs...
- Avec le caméraman Alexey
Sergeev dont la lentille a c
et documenté la suite.
- Les soldats russes bloquent
toujours l'entrée, ils disent...
- Avec Alexandra Szacka et
Jean-François Bélanger, ils ont
témoigné des ambitions d'un
régime de plus en plus
belliqueste
Raymond St-Pierre, il a vu son
propre pays se refermer à
nouveau. Et ces dernières années
auront été marqué par
la répression de ceux qui
osaient encore tenir tête au
régime.
(cris des manifestants)
Cette photo avec l'opposant
Vladimir Kara-Mourza a été prise
il y a moins d'un an, à Moscou.
Il est désormais en prison pour
avoir critiqué l'opération
militaire du président.
Cette carte nous aura guidés
jusqu'à la toute dernièreminutee
éclate aux frontières de
l'Ukraine.Ça, c'est la Russie te
qu'elle, mais Vladimir Poutine,
si on se fie à ces derniers
discours, en tout cas,
veulent t.
L'Ukraine.
Et qui sait ce que l'avenir
réserve?
Anastasia, elle, était la plus
jeune de notre équipe.
Elle incarne cette génération,
toujours optimiste, même dansle.
Radio-Canada, au fil du temps,
aura été là pour les hauts et
pour les bas.
On va la garder, l
C'est plus de 30 ans d'histoire
de Radio-Canada en Russie. Et
autant les choses sont arrivées
vite, autant on espère qu'elles,
mais ça, ça s'en va dans
les bagages et on espère que
ce n'est qu'un au revoir.
Ici Tamara Alterersco,
Radio-Canada, à